hmm doesn't simply be a listing for
George banks here
[Music]
MARY POPPINS returns the concept seems
like an unnecessary sequel the execution
a really unnecessary sequel with evil
bankers kidnapping wolves chase scenes a
complete lack of focus in both character
and story it was a mess but it's one
thing to criticize it's another to offer
a solution that will never get me but
it's still fun to theorize how a piece
of art could be made better and as far
the fun of being an artist always trying
to find ways to improve and make an even
bigger impact well the original Mary
Poppins left a big impact on me and I
think I owe it to such a wonderful film
to try and fix this emotionally lacking
sequel now par for how this show works I
do need some rules and guidelines the
actors must stay the same the very
general idea and plot must be the same
and as an extra bonus the songs must be
the same which I don't mind as I love
the songs and feel they deserve a better
movie to go with it with that said
here's how I would fix Mary Poppins
Returns
after the opening credits with those
cool paintings we get straight to the
point and see grown-up Michael being
told by the bank that his house is going
to be repossessed unless he can get them
the money in five days Michael explains
how his wife who passed away last year
handled all the finances and how he
hasn't had a job in a year due to grief
he is clearly a very lost man the bank
is sympathetic but still firm that
unless payment is received he'll lose
his home this not only reduces ten
minutes of boring bank talk to just a
few minutes but it sets up right away
that this time around there's bigger
threats and consequences and honestly
that's about as much of the bank as we
see no evil bad guy throwing information
in the fire no symbolic wolves with
watches that somehow mean don't trust
them this Mary Poppins like the last one
has no villain Michael walks home slowly
in the days across the street we see
jack lighting a street lamp he sees the
devastated look on Michaels face and
though he doesn't know him decides to
light the lamps behind him while
cheerfully singing the lovely London sky
song this song now has a purpose it's
trying to show that even in the darkest
times there is light if you go searching
for it Michael looks up only once or
twice even noticing that he's singing
mostly remaining in a deep depression as
he walks home as the song wraps up a
water balloon is dropped on a
well-dressed lady with a dog the classic
upscale stereotype she looks up and sees
Michael's daughter Annabelle snickering
in a tree with a box of water balloons
next to her
this prank can be replaced with
something else I'm not even sure of
water balloons were a thing back then
but somehow she's annoying people and oh
yeah Annabelle is the only kid keep it
simple there's no reason to have more
than one it's just unneeded characters
you have to develop taking time away
from the focus I chose the girl because
the boy got a hint more attention in the
original but honestly the character is
pretty gender neutral so if for some
reason it had to be changed to a boy
that could be done - however unlike the
other Poppins movies this kid is a legit
brat not like oh they chased after a
kite what nightmares I mean like lilo
from lilo and Stitch Bratz
she's always attacking people always
playing pranks always making up insults
and worst of all she's good at it
Michael sees what Annabelle did and
calmly expresses his disappointment the
woman is furious that he isn't harsher
on her as Annabelle makes faces at her
while Michael does very little about it
the comedy can really be played up here
on how rebellious yet clearly
intelligent Annabelle is with her pranks
and insults hey lady she says what is
till age five eyes and sharp teeth the
lady's still dumbfounded begrudgingly
ass I don't know what hey if you don't
know what's in your hair how should I
know
the lady freaks out thinking there's
something in her hair Michael remains a
pushover hardly doing anything during
the seat Michael takes Annabelle home as
she keeps cracking inappropriate jokes
Jane meets him there as Michael explains
to her the bad news as they tried to
figure out what to do and about climbs
the bookcase and jumps off it forcing
Michael to catch her he gets annoyed
asking her why she does things like this
mom would let me do it she says this
throws might go off and she knows this
throws Michael off no she wouldn't he
responds yes she would yes she would she
screams over and over go to your room
your your he stutters clearly having no
idea how to punish her you're not to
have dinner tonight
Jane gives him a look as if that's too
harsh and above gets angry and stomps up
the stairs mom definitely wouldn't do
that she yells you don't know what she
would do Michael screams back you're
right and I never will she slams the
door
Michael is shaken for obvious reasons
Jane goes upstairs and talks to
Annabelle who's pouting in bed your
father who loves you very much
she tells her he's going through a lot
right now and about bitterly asks just
him Michael goes to the Attic to look at
his wife's belongings including a
collection of songs on sheet music with
both their names on it he sings the
conversation song pretty similar to how
it was in the film that's a pretty good
scene so I wouldn't change much about it
also like in the film Jane at him search
through the Attic but not for any lost
proof of shares but rather things they
can sell to possibly raise money to save
the house while looking Michael comes
across the kite look at this rubbish he
says Michael how could you chamber
spawns don't you remember all the fun we
had with this but it's ruined Michael
says it's not ruined Jane responds it
just needs some mending while Jane goes
to search for other items Michael tosses
the kite out the window as if his
chowder dreams have betrayed him we see
Annabelle sneak out of her room with a
giant box of matches and bottles filled
with god knows what we have no idea what
she's going to do with them she turns
and sees the kite on the ground and go
to grab the string to pull it closer the
kite flies into the air dragging her
with it similar to what happened to the
boy in the movie except it drags are in
a much more wild and over-the-top manner
having more fun with the idea like
before Jack Caesar and tries to pull her
back to the ground when lo and behold
Mary Poppins grabs the kayid and floats
down to the ground a lot of this is like
in the film with Poppins saying hi to
Jack taking Annabelle back to Michael
and Poppins offering her services as a
nanny the only difference is Annabelle
doesn't want a nanny and every time she
tries throwing a witty insult at her
Mary always has a clever one right back
hey Mary she taunts what has three
mouths two noses Mary interrupts her by
saying and about what best fighter off
your shoulder and about streams batting
at her shoulder there's nothing innocent
mistake this leads to the bathtub scene
after Jane gets filthy chasing after the
kite Poppins sinks the song can you
imagine that and again it's pretty close
to the film except Annabelle isn't
delighted she's freaked out her cynical
bratty mind can't accept the magic going
on around her and she constantly looks
confused horrified and usually tries to
cling on to something for dear life
Poppins on the other hand enjoys
watching Annabelle overreact knowing the
situation is totally under control
afterwards Annabelle tries tattling on
Mary explaining the strange adventures
she just took her on but of course Mary
denies it and the father thinks she's
just pretending
the following day Michael tries selling
a bunch of their belongings in the park
trying to raise money
letting out an occasional Annabelle stay
close now Annabelle of course is not
doing as she's told and once again tries
dropping balloons on people until she
sees Mary checking her appearance in a
compact and about tries dropping a
balloon on Mary's noggin but somehow it
drops on Annabelle's hat instead she
tries it again and once more it lands on
her own head like she somehow dropping
it on herself
Mary smiles and closes her compact
pretending she doesn't notice Annabelle
what did you do to yourself Mary asks
Annabelle has no answer what are you
even covered in Mary continues do we
have to take another bath no and abell
quickly answers yes good cold Mary says
you look drenched enough already and a
Belsen tears at her Jamie while tells
Michael that she may have found him a
job as a newsie now again this can
honestly be any low-level job on the
street at the time but I'm just going
with this one Jane tells him where to go
to apply while she takes
for selling the belongings the following
day while Michael works Jean brings in
the ceramic bowl to show Annabelle
saying they might be able to sell it for
enough money for what they need like in
the movie Annabelle breaks the bowl and
Poppins takes herself Annabelle and Jack
inside the design singing the Royal
Doulton musical here though it doesn't
just stop there Jack asked Mary for
another song but she and says no other
works of art in the room want to hear
her sing it referring to the characters
in the ceramic bowl Jack gives a whistle
and suddenly all the paintings all the
books even the drawings Annabelle
doodles on the ground come to life and
come forward to her Mary and Jack then
sing a cover is not the book while
actually jumping into books as well as
paintings and drawings all around the
room every time they jump into a
different piece of art they take on
whatever style it has line draw an
illustration abstract painting
watercolors you can have a ton of fun
with this that way you're not just doing
the simple inside the drawing bit again
you're going into a bunch of different
art styles all over the room upping the
creativity a lot more and yeah no
bullshit chase scenes with dumb ass
wolves the books all apply by simply
opening and closing their covers as
Annabelle is amazed and delighted
[Music]
afterwards Michael comes home from work
and is exhausted as he had to work
longer hours to try and make more money
to save the house Annabelle tries
telling both Jane and Michael the Great
Adventure she went on but they ignore
her trying to figure out if what they're
doing will be enough to save the house
Annabelle grabs a glass and tosses it to
the ground getting their attention you
never listen to me she mutters quietly
she goes upstairs and locks herself in
her room Michael tries to talk to her
through the door but she clearly doesn't
want to listen to him later in the night
Mary knocks on her door saying she needs
to get the linens from her room
Annabelle lets her in saying I don't
want to talk about it no I wasn't aware
I was asking for it Mary responds I'm
only here for the linens as Mary's
silence fills the room Annabelle slowly
starts to talk about how she used to get
along with her dad a lot more when her
mom was alive this leads to Mary singing
where the loss things go this time with
a much greater understanding of how the
mother's death affected the family as a
whole
it isn't just briefly talked about it's
felt through all of their actions the
following morning and above finds the
sheet music with the songs on it that
Michael left out she asked Mary if she
could read the music for her remembering
how her mom used to really enjoy singing
Mary starts to sing a slower tempo
version of there's no place to go but up
however she doesn't get very far and
stops saying that the song isn't
finished and about really likes the song
she began though and suggests the idea
that maybe they finish it this leads to
a rendition of the song being sung as
they put it together with the piano
playing itself musical notes and lyrics
flying around the room and a pen writing
it all down as they sing well great work
often writes itself Mary jokes sometimes
the song can even stop as they tried to
think of a rhyme similar to part of your
world when Ariel tries to think of what
certain objects are called
once they complete the song though
Annabelle accidentally spills ink all
over it Oh No Annabelle screams now it's
lost forever hmm Mary Ponder's I think I
know someone who can help Mary and
Annabelle then go to her cousin who
asked if she can think of a way to fix
the ink all over the song this is where
the turning turtle song is song about
trying to find an upside-down way of
looking at things to fix the problem
this time though the room isn't just
upside down
it keeps spinning sideways up ways down
waves build a whole room that rotates
it's been done a million
times in the past and your Disney you
can afford it really go all out taking V
I love to laugh scenario and pushing it
to the next level
well upside-down Annabelle nois is
something on the back of the song and
gets an idea she rushes back home with
Mary and notices the pen left an indent
on the paper under the one it was
writing up so they can make out the
notes and the lyric that were originally
written down they transcribe it to
another sheet of paper and once again
the song lives
Annabelle rushes to her dad to tell her
the good idea she had but notices the
bank people are at the front doors
shaking their heads at Michael who was
attempting to hand them a small bit of
money Michael walks into the living room
and starts throwing what few belongings
they have left and drops to his knees
and tears
Annabelle starts crying - she runs up to
her room and sneaks out the window she
runs to the park where she used to drop
balloons on people and realize that she
has no idea where she's going she sits
down in the cold dark night all curled
up Jack discovers her as he's lighting
the lamps and she tells him that she's
running away he's too angry to have me
there she says I'll only make things
worse
I always make things worse some of
Jack's friends gather around her and try
to cheer her up
this results in trip a little light
fantastic but this time the lamplighters
start lighting the stars using the
sticks to move them around and make
pictures out of them Mary Poppins
eventually flies in looking for
Annabelle and they encourage her to play
along she of course does lifting
everybody into the Stars where they
swing on the images through
constellations like snowballs and have a
magically creative time again it's like
taking step in time to the stars
doing something similar but still
different upping the game after calming
down Annabelle realizes she should go
back home and act more grown-up Poppins
takes her home as Michael tries
apologizing to her but Annabelle
interrupts apologizing to him they both
hug and realize they'd be truly lost
without one another cut to them packing
all their belongings like in the movie
getting ready to live at Jane's house
Poppins makes the sad announcement that
as she has no house to nanion she can no
longer be under Michaels employment
don't worry this isn't as bad as you
think
Annabelle looks shocked as Mary
apologizes saying she must find
employment elsewhere
she then approaches Jane standing right
next to Michaels saying I present my
services as nanny for the new members of
your house change shrugs you're hired
a little bit levity in an otherwise very
heavy scene you see unlike the dumbass
climax where they have to stop the big
bad bang from taking the house here
there's consequences for their actions
and they actually do lose the house yeah
no going back cease when Bambi's mom
dies she stays dead when the toys leave
Andi they stay gone and when a family
slips so far they can't pay for a house
they lose the house their slow ride away
from the house to Jane's home would
probably mimic mr. banks walking to his
job to get fired similar but still very
different both represent the lowest
moment for our characters once they get
to Jane's house Michael and Annabelle
share a room he tries to hold back tears
but finds he's unable to Annabelle
finally tries to take some
responsibility and takes on the role as
parent she pulls out the song that she
had folded up in her pocket and starts
singing in a slow calm tempo there's no
place to go but up
Michael recognizes the song and admits
it was something he was working on with
her mother but it was never finished
because she passed away
well Annabelle says I guess we all
finished it
Michael smiles and gives her a hug so
yes how does it go again they both start
softly singing the song together as it
dissolves to the next day seeing Michael
selling papers
he seems glum until Annabelle approaches
him and starts singing the song there's
no place to go but up again only this
time in his more upbeat tempo Michael
starts singing along with her and the
more he sings the happier he gets as
days go by at the job he continues to
sing the song as if the louder he sings
it the happier he becomes often
Annabelle we either be alongside him or
be coming home from school and join him
it turns out both the song and his
energy are incredibly contagious soon
everybody who gets a paper from him
starts singing it too over the passing
days everybody knows the song is singing
it constantly and it just gets grander
and grander both Annabelle and Michael's
attitudes have changed as they seem to
have no physical possessions but they
still have each other suddenly an old
talent scout passes by been played by
Welles Dick Van Dyke he says he's been
hearing that song all over town and
everybody said he was coming from a
newsie in these parts the Scout explains
that he used to be a song-and-dance man
himself and also got started in this
but now he looks for great talent
wherever he can find it I don't want to
necessarily cement that this is burnt
it's left a little vague so you can draw
your own conclusion maybe there can be
him or maybe it's not I don't even know
if the years would add up so maybe it's
just Dick Van Dyke as a talents gap
regardless he asks if there's any more
songs like that and Michael assures him
that there's tons the Scout asked
Michael if they can have a sit-down at
his office tomorrow and see if they can
figure out something they can do with
those tons of songs now it's important
that we never see the actual meeting
happen or figure out if he does this for
a living from now on it's more about his
change of attitude working hard and
being creative wherever he can that can
lead you in the right direction after
that we do like the movie where Angela
Lansbury starts handing out balloons
everybody takes them and floats in the
air and the one only change here is
Poppins exit we see Jack flying the torn
of kite as Mary walks up beside him
smiling once again he says you made
something beautiful out of leftover
ruins Mary smirks
Oh was never ruined it just needed to be
mended she opens her umbrella and flies
into the sky as Michael on Annabelle
continued to laugh so that's how I would
mend Mary Poppins returns is it as good
as the original Mary Poppins of course
not but nothing can top that but it does
up everything a bit more the thread is
much more threatening the challenges are
much more challenging the lessons are
much more aggressive but still coming
back to a gentle kindness and grand
creativity in my opinion this doesn't
quite copy the original as much as
follow a particular style the James Bond
movies don't usually have the exact same
plot but there's a definite way they
tell their stories that you associate as
a James Bond movie this is the same idea
it adds more drama and conflict than the
first film but it's mature in its
handling of it while innocent and
imaginative in is more pleasant moments
I'm sure there's gonna be people who
miss the mean vicious bankers the
maniacal laughing wolves and the
action-packed climax but if you're
looking for something more mature subtle
and carries a lot of weight to it you
know like a Mary Poppins movie I think
this one's a little closer is it
practically perfect no but I think it's
a decent follow up
but maybe I'm wrong maybe this is too
heavy and a simple bad guy was what
logically lied ahead for these movies do
you think this fixes the problems if not
how would you fix it up
what would your version of Mary Poppins
Returns be like let us know in the
comments thanks for listening to me
ramble about a sequel to one of my
favorite films and if there's anything
that didn't make sense to you remember I
don't have to explain anything
[Music]
you